welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host de Laura I mean definition and
this episode were breaking down one of
the big theories surrounding Westworld
that is that everything exists within a
simulation whether it's an alternate
reality the mirror world or everyone
being a host the Internet is currently
buzzing with ideas on what's going on
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing the best theories and the
evidence to support them so if you want
to know why everything may not be as it
seems then this is the video for you
that will of course be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't watched episode 4
of season 3 then I highly suggest that
you turn off now we'll also be talking
about leaks that dropped on the overall
arc of the show way back in season 1 and
though they should be taken with a pinch
of salt they could potentially ruin
things going forward if you still here
thanks for sticking with me now let's
get into our breakdown of the west-world
simulation theory ok so the simulation
with an assimilation theory is something
that's existed since the show's first
season
way back when Dolores who was still
enjoying the world full of splendor and
apparent insider on the show leaked the
entire plot to Reddit they said that in
Westworld nobody is human and that
everything is taking place within a
three-step a AI pyramid that
demonstrates hierarchies within society
and how the upper levels ultimately
treat the ones below them with disdain
the lower part were not aware of the
existence of any machines and these were
the hosts the next part up with the
humans such as William and Logan and
they were aware of the hosts but did not
believe that they were machines
themselves at the top of the pyramid was
the level that had complete
self-awareness and control over all of
those below that would be you sir axe
you Fords and people at the pinnacle
though it was disregarded as we got
further into the show the theory once
more picked up steam with the release of
season 3 episode 1 this is because
during scene the lovable rogue Roderick
stated that there would be a lot of
irony if the world was just a simulation
within a simulation though a lot of
people thought this was just the
creative team poking fun at the audience
it's still something that a lot of
viewers including myself can't get out
of our heads the line was intentionally
put in the episode to draw attention to
this possibility and whether
secluded the truth or simply just a fun
red herring it does cause a lot of
speculation now firstly the poster for
Westworld season 3 could indicate that
there indeed exists a false world that
has been pulled over everyone's eyes it
shows a desert wasteland with a machine
hunched over in front of a decimated
City everything is in ruins and it's a
completely different world had the one
that we've seen in the show this far in
the reality that Caleb exists in there's
no hint of war and civilization seems to
be at its height so why choose this for
the poster when it hasn't appeared in
the season at all this far either
they're spoiling what's to come in the
finale or they're in fact showing us the
true world and how it really exists it
is possible that because of the
destruction we saw CEREC witness
firsthand in Paris that he decided to
create a simulation similar to the
matrix which people could live in
instead of the real world here they
would be safe from the terrors of the
war and they'd be able to live in a
world full of splendor so sorry for
Sahaba there
Sarah clearly has access to VR
technology as we see him use it on a
gangster to show them their family's
future
dolorous use this in episode 1 and
there's a lot of terrifying potential
within the tech the gang member arrives
in horror at the visions he receives and
if Sarah can invoke this emotion with
just a pair of glasses imagine what he
could do with the proper equipment we
already know that he has facilities that
specialize in virtual reality and that
takes us to our next point which is
Maeve in the winter line we picked it
with maven Warworld or at the very least
a recreation of it may have realized
that she was trapped inside a simulation
and everyone in it was a digital
recreation they were unaware of this
which did show that digital versions of
people could believe their own realities
and may was only able to escape by
creating a paradox within the system in
her escape attempt she was able to go up
one level and control the drone that we
saw was in a facility with countless
pearls all plugged in this could show
that there were more pearls plugged into
war world such as Lise Sizemore and
Hector or it could indeed show that
there are several other realities all
going on at once
clearly Sarah has other hosts plugged in
that are being fed their own realities
and it does add weight to the theory
that this is going on on a mass scale
now before discussing the other
indicators
that show the world does not truly exist
we have to talk about Rehoboam this is
the machine that was created by CEREC
after he apparently saw the devastation
that free will can cause firsthand this
led to the destruction of his home Paris
and he built the machine to create a
path that every person on the planet
would follow these pre-assign loops
would avert any Wars going forward and
it would enslave everyone into a prison
that they could neither see or touch
Sarek wishes to collect the data that
Delores stole from West world in order
to better understand human behavior and
therefore he'll be able to make more
accurate predictions the system is far
more complex than that but that's the
basic overview of how it works if you
want another show that deals with a
similar aesthetic then I highly
recommend devs because because that's
just really good as well yeah definitely
check that out anyway another indicator
that this is all a simulation is the big
new character in season 3 that is Caleb
though he does seem real there are
several indicators that he isn't firstly
he wakes up extremely similar to how
Dolores did in episode 1 and even his
origin story does somewhat have a
similar editing style to hers they
mirror each other quite a lot and these
parallels will likely put in place for a
reason we learned that when caleb was in
the army he was shot in the head and
then he also lost his combat partner and
best friend so yeah being shot in the
head and still walking around fine
especially in TV shows it does seem a
bit iffy because in fiction that's just
normally a death sentence we learned
that caleb has depression and he
initially uses an AI recreation of his
friend for therapy Caleb's mother does
not recognize him and this could
indicate that he himself is not a real
person where this falls down is that
Dolores does inject blood in him to
break an encryption program but this
could just be a characteristic of those
on the middle tier of the pyramid who
had the ability to take blood from one
another
Caleb lives in an almost Grand Theft
Auto like world where crimes are carried
out in exchange for cash I have seen
theories that Caleb in fact exists
within the Ricoh app and that Dolores
has broken into it to recruit soldiers
but I think it goes beyond that if this
theory is true then the entire world is
a simulation caleb states to Dolores
that she's the only thing that feels
real to him anymore
and this could be because she's broken
into the simulated reality in order to
free those within who are unaware of the
prison that surrounds them
Dolores does mention that Rehoboam has
created a mirror world within its
systems and using this it's predicted
how Kayla will eventually die which we
see play out on screen now is possible
at the death that we see for caleb did
actually happen in the real world for in
the future
Sarek was around when this happened and
it's also when the nuke started flying
leading to the destruction of Paris if
this theory is true then after the war
was over and the world was in ruins
Sarah decided that the only way to save
humanity was to rewind the clocks and go
to a time before the war in his creation
it is possible that Rehoboam is able to
so accurately predict the future because
it's already happened for it therefore
it can go back to the time when all of
the data and humanity was collected run
its simulation up to the war and then if
it likes reset everything and just run
through the loop once more
dolorous appearing in this simulation
when she wasn't there in the past would
lead to a divergence an anomaly which is
why Sarah causes eyes on her perhaps
this is why Caleb states that she feels
real because she has actually come from
the real world in order to save him even
the world that we see in between shots
looks like Rehoboam and a circular shape
of it being a planet mimics our own
world in its design for a reason
even Sarah himself is an anomaly and is
possible at the one we come face-to-face
with is a simulation whilst the real one
exists on the outside world
there's simply no trace that Sarah ever
existed and for the richest man in the
world covering himself up would be
extremely difficult
he's been wiped from every system on the
planet and only something controlling
all could likely accomplish this if this
is a simulation then it is possible that
Dolores will want to cause an uprising
and this could bring it all crashing
down similar to what we saw with maven
episode 2 this was on a smaller scale so
it may have been easier to overload
whereas this will take a lot more
firepower in the trailer for episode 5
Dolores utters the line that it's time
everyone woke up and then she stabs
Caleb and he wakes up slightly unaware
of his surroundings this indicates that
he's in unknown territory and it could
also add a way to the Mara well theory
which is another alternate one to the
simulation within a simulation you
definitely want to hear that but before
we get into it I just wanna let you know
we're giving away a free copy of the
Star Wars Skywalker saga box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in with a chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts and theories in the
comments section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of April
and the subtle be shipped out from then
to ever gets the prize - best of luck to
everyone who takes part okay so the
mirror world theory though similar in
principle does differ slightly from the
simulation within a simulation one as
mentioned earlier dolorous did tell
Caleb that there was a mirror world
within Rehoboam she said that before
privacy laws existed everyone's raw data
was fed into the machine and this
allowed the algorithm to be created this
included all text messages job searches
calls medical history and so on and it
all got recorded and put into the system
I used to be a web developer before
doing YouTube and before releasing code
to live websites and applications you
would always test it on your local
network to see that it wouldn't cause
any errors it is possible that Rehoboam
is a sort of dev environment in which
those in control can run live tests and
then see how they play out before
releasing them to the world season one
and two of Westworld dealt with
different timelines so it is possible at
season 3 deals with different worlds
it's also possible that we've been
watching the mirror world so far which
is a recreation by Rehoboam in
preparation for the upcoming battle the
system is trying to work out all of the
anomalies and divergences in order to
succeed against Deloris it's even
possible that the scenes we've been
watching play out have some in the
mirror world and some in the real one
and that serac exists within the fake
reality he's trying the avenue with may
Bursar's Deloris to see what the outcome
will be and there is potential that this
could be revealed in the upcoming
episodes we do get the feeling that
there are alternate versions of events
which is shown in the message from hale
to a son we see this happened two times
in an episode and yet the dialogue is
delivered slightly differently in both
let's take a look
[Music]
okay so as you can hear the line
delivery is slightly different and this
could show that the simulation is
getting the majority of things right but
the minor details are incorrect even the
position of Hale looks a mirrored so
yeah there's definitely subtext within
this it is possible that serac wants the
data collected by Dolores from Westworld
in order to create a more accurate
simulation and this would allow minor
inconsistencies like this to be fully
ruled out whilst we won't know if this
is true until the show progresses
overall it's a lot to get you
questioning your own reality and
definitely think it allows a number of
things even for characters to return
from the dead I don't know which theory
is right or if either are but yeah
there's a ton of things going on now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the theories and which side of the
fence that you fall on comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please drop a thumbs up and make
sure you check out a breakdown of
episode four which is gonna be linked at
the end we go over the best theories in
regards to the show so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more you want to support the channel
from its letters ninety nine cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and a thank
you you get access to content early you
want to come chat to us after the show
either follow us at definition whitey or
click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]